Concentrate taken all that is around you.
Let's go again.
Ahsoka Tano
Anakin spoke highly of you.
I have reason to believe
Thrawn is still a threat.
We face another war.
Let's begin.
You're ready.
Nice trick.
Got any more?
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This is the way
we've got a bunch of Ahsoka
episode
4 trailer footage to break down.
There's a bunch more Easter eggs
and references.
There's a lot of questions that they're
starting to answer to a lot more.
And again, Skywalker references as well.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'm doing videos for all the episodes,
be sure to subscribe to get them.
We're also in the middle of the Star Wars
echo dot giveaway on them.
A winner during this video
to Careful for spoilers for episode three
if you haven't seen it yet.
But a lot of the episode was dedicated
to setting up all the big lightsaber
fights that they'll be having
during episode four.
Like now it's finally time to rumble.
A whole bunch of rematches.
The other big thing is episode four
is like the halfway point in the series.
It makes sense
that that would be a much bigger episode
where they pay off a lot of things
after at least some of the big long
running questions and teasers
like who is Morales character really?
what's really going on with Ezra Bridger?
When are they going to bring Thrawn back?
Like, when will they actually show them on
screen
and what are they going to do with Jacen?
Since Dula, who's also for sensitive
at the end of episode
three, Baylan Skoll had just ordered
pretty much all their forces to hunt down.
So can Sabine kill them?
Based on the trailer footage,
pretty obvious that they take off
running from her ship into the forest
and use that for cover.
And they might be just taking out
all the unnamed mercenaries versus
before they set up the big rematches,
the lightsaber fights
the way they're framing these fight
scenes, too.
You can actually see both of their fights
going on at the same time in the woods,
like they switched perspectives.
You could see the other fight
in the background.
Sabine having a rematch with Shin Hati,
I know there's tons of questions about her
surviving that light saber stab in episode
one way more than I expected.
I think the idea here is the whole PG 13
rating on Phantom Menace with Qui Gon
Jinn dying because he got stabbed
in what looked like the stomach.
So like wouldn't he be able to survive
because that's the whole idea
with all these characters in present day
surviving the lightsaber stabs.
Oh, it happened in the stomach.
wasn't a critical organ.
It cauterized the wound.
So as long as they were near a back door
tank or a medical droid,
they could have survived that. ba ba.
Then you have all the funny memes about
Qui Gon like,
No, we're on Naboo.
Like, apparently
there's no back to takes on here.
There's no medical droids around.
So we're just going to let you die.
probably what happened is that George
Lucas in the Star Wars, people
at the time when they were making
Phantom Menace, were worried about the PG
13 rating and didn't want it to get rated
R like something more hardcore,
because if he got stabbed in a grisly
or way to make it more clear
that he was stabbed in a critical organ,
it's one of those problems
you run into where movies are made
for like general audiences,
like they wanted
kids to be able to go see the movie,
so they didn't want it to be too crazy.
I remember seeing the Deadpool movie,
which is obviously very clearly rated R
with a bunch of families
and young kids going to see it
because it was a superhero movie.
but then you get to all those scenes
of Deadpool doing all this really,
really over-the-top crazy stuff
that you would never see in a PG 13 movie
and just families walking out left and
right just because it was so, so crazy.
in back in the day.
George Lucas wanted Kwai Gone Jin to die
but didn't want the movie to be rated R.
The other funny thing about that too, is
that Darth Maul got chopped
in half by Obi-Wan Kenobi lightsaber
and still survived.
But that was George Lucas.
According to Dave Filoni,
who brought him on to do the Clone Wars
like he was hired to do the Clone Wars
series and said,
We're bringing Darth Maul back like George
Lucas had already decided to bring Darth
Maul back when Dave Filoni was hired.
So when it came to his character,
it was kind of more of a hand
waving thing like,
you know, we want him back for the series.
So we're just going to say that
he survived,
either way, Sabine in present day
still vastly outmatched by Chinnery
who's just had way,
way more training than her recently.
So I think the best outcome for her
in this rematch
is that she doesn't get stabbed again.
It manages to hold her at bay.
maybe they wind up paying off
the circus lesson
about how the dark side of the force
can make you physically
a more powerful fighter,
but also cloud your mind, unbalances
you, leaving you more prone to attacks.
So Sabine might be able to land
a couple of small blows on her or too
enough to allow her to escape.
Right now, just based on the way
they're plotting the series,
I'm pretty sure that she in
Haiti will be in most of the episodes.
Merak will see.
It depends on who the character winds
up. Being.
Ahsoka is not one to show that much mercy,
especially to inquisitors.
Merak surviving his rematch with her
is completely dependent
on whether or not he's going to wind up
being a huge twist.
Reveal character.
right now
they're all the same Witwer theories.
I don't expect
him to be a version of Star Killer,
even though Sam Witwer just did a long Q&A
where he talked about Star Killer
being an inquisitor
who Darth Vader
secretly trained as an apprentice,
and he shows up in these other
additional voices
during all the episodes in Morocco,
The Voice does sound a little bit
like a modulated version
of Sam Witwer. His voice
discuss the concept of Starkiller
as an inquisitor.
Like Well, I know that, Dave, at one point
when you were doing Star Wars rebels
thought about including him
as an inquisitor.
out how to how to pitch a story around it.
But the main ingredients would have to be
that you have to have
a personal relationship
to Vader in The Apprentice
totally fine to listen to him
talk about Star Wars minutia.
He's a way bigger fanboy than a lot of
the people who actually work on Star Wars.
He said that he even got
the job is the voice of Darth
Maul back in the day doing Clone Wars
because he corrected Dave Filoni
during his audition
about some of the canon,
some of the character details,
and he thought that he messed up
at the time,
like, Oh, no,
I shouldn't have said anything.
They're going to hate me.
But Dave Filoni was like, You're perfect.
You're hired.
that's also become part of Dave
Filoni job.
On the more modern Mandalorian series.
Like when he and Jon Favreau are working
on story details, it's Dave Filoni job
to sort of make sure that all fits within
preexisting canon.
right now,
my assumption, without having absolute
confirmation who Merauke is, Ahsoka breaks
is masked during the fight,
revealing who he really is
answering a lot of those questions.
And if he's just a normal inquisitor,
like he's nobody's special.
Just like a totally new character,
Ahsoka will probably kill him.
And that's the last we'll see of him.
but if he does wind up being a huge
reveal character like some huge twist,
like a dark version of Ezra Bridger
or someone else, then Ahsoka might wind up
sparing his life.
the other interesting Merak detail
that a lot of you were asking about
after episode three
is that during the intro, when it cycles
through all the helmets and droid heads,
Merak inquisitor
helmet was lit with blue light.
normally you'd think that would be a clue.
Like, Wait a minute, does that mean
that he's secretly a good character?
There's going to be some huge twists.
But the other thing, too,
is that Sabine's
Mandalorian helmet was lit with Sith red.
So I don't know if we should look
too deeply into that detail
or if it was just like
some weird one off thing.
so we'll just have to see what they wind
up revealing about the character.
either way, pretty easy to assume
Ahsoka defeats Merak
and then makes her way to the waypoint
where she fights Baylan Skoll,
who'll probably be way too powerful
for her to defeat.
And I think that's part of the idea
is that he was a fully trained
Jedi Knight before Order 66,
and he was powerful enough
to defeat the clone troopers
that tried to kill him in over the years
just became more and more powerful
while he was working as a mercenary
in the outer rim,
trying to see off the Emperor
and Darth Vader's radar
mostly because he didn't want Darth
Vader in the inquisitors to show up
and either force him
to become another inquisitor
or try to kill him,
because those are basically
the two options for force sensitive people
during the rise of the Empire Right
now, the reason why Morag, who is a former
inquisitor, is serving under him, is only
because there's no more inquisitorial.
So he doesn't have any rules.
The Emperor's orders to follow any more.
And he's way more powerful than Barack
during their fight scenes,
they have all these lines of dialog
from him talking about Anakin Skywalker
and his history
with Darth Vader in order 66.
I think the idea is that he's
meant to be around
the same age as Anakin Skywalker,
just looking at him like in present day,
if Darth Vader had survived
Return of the Jedi
Anakin
Skywalker would be in his fifties.
But after order 66.
I think the idea is that Baylan Skoll did not agree with the Sith way
of thinking didn't want of anything
to do with Darth Vader or the Emperor.
So he just stayed off of their radar.
But he does still lean a bit dark side,
like he's a little more like the bend.
Do The difference with the actual Bender
character from Star Wars Rebels,
who's played by Tom Baker from Doctor Who.
That was actually a pretty cool Easter egg
when it actually aired,
is that he's meant to be a true
neutral type of character,
both the light side
in the dark side in equal amounts.
Baylan Skoll
and Shin Hati lightsabers are orange,
meaning that they're probably leaning
a little bit more dark side than that.
the other side of that equation
would be characters like Ahsoka,
for instance, in Grogu who don't believe
in all the Jedi orders rules,
like she was arguing with who Yang about
that the last couple of episodes,
particularly in Grogu's case,
do when it comes to attachment.
they basically been trying
to use the last couple of seasons
on The Mandalorian to show you that it's
okay to have attachments in relationships
and still be a light side Jedi.
Like still be a good person.
they kind of got into this
during the Legends canon
with Luke Skywalker in Mara Jade,
who is also a big
part of the Thrawn trilogy,
or the original Thrawn trilogy,
not expecting Mara Jade
to show up in present day,
but I know a lot of people
keep asking you about that.
Every time there's a new Star Wars show
or they announce the Thrawn movies
the idea was, though, that Luke Skywalker
actually got married to her
and had a son, Ben
Skywalker, named after Obi-Wan Kenobi.
So legends.
Luke was a little bit more like Rogue,
who in that way,
like he does recreate his own
Jedi Academy, but it's not strictly
based on the exact teaching and rules
of the original Jedi Order.
They take things
in a completely new direction,
which is kind of what they're doing with
some of these other characters, like Roku
based on the way
they're plotting the series out.
Since we know Thrawn is coming back
anyway,
they probably end this episode episode
four with the So Considine barely escaping
with their lives and Morgan Elsbeth
completing her hyperdrive,
bringing the eye of Scion
they probably at least begin the process
of bringing Thrawn back,
but I'm not expecting to see him
till a little bit later in the series.
there were a couple other characters
that they created as underlings for Thrawn
that had been with him
in that other galaxy.
It sounds like
they're in multiple episodes,
so we might actually get to see Thrawn
by episode five or Episode six.
I don't expect them to wait
till like the very final episode
to show him or Ezra Bridger
a lot of people
asking about Jacen Sandoval, and now too,
because he's for sensitive,
are they going to tease Ahsoka
thinking about training him
later in the series
when that's going to happen?
There's already this plot
with her training Sabine Wren right now
in Thrawn coming back, then finding
Ezra Bridger it feels like short term.
If they do tease Jacen being more
sensitive and Ahsoka needing to train him,
they'll probably use it as a way
to balance out Sabine's arc like more
in a jokey, comedic kind of way
where she has trouble doing basic things.
But Jacen can using stuff like Grogu using
stuff through the force to eat or drink,
whereas Sabine has a really hard time
doing stuff like that.
but yes, definitely.
In the future Ahsoka would be training
Jacen before he gets way older.
Dave Filoni said when they introduced
the character at the very end of Star Wars
Rebels, he didn't completely have an idea
of what the Star Wars
people wanted to use the character for
or what
they planned for him in the future,
only that they wanted him to exist.
Like, okay, we'll just figure this out
with the character,
what we're going to do with him
much, much later.
now we're getting to much, much later.
They can just continue
with this character in present day
or they can recast him with a much older
version in the events of the sequel.
Movies like he could be
in those sequel movies as a Jedi Knight.
since there's so many Anakin
Skywalker references in these
last couple of trailers,
especially in this upcoming fight
with Balan's scope,
we'll probably get an antique
and Skywalker actual cameo.
Seems pretty soon,
but that might not be episode five
because that's kind of the way they paced
out the Obi-Wan Kenobi series too,
where they had a bunch of references to
and acted like they had Darth Vader too,
because of the plot of the Obi-Wan
Kenobi series.
But they had a bunch of anarchist
and references
before they actually had an anarchist
flashback.
the big difference this time, though, is
they've never actually done
a live action scene
with Anarchist in Ahsoka together.
Supposedly
they also cast a different actress
to play a much younger version of Ahsoka.
So we'll see about that.
That's just a rumor.
the only other big thing too is
what's really going on with the pergolas,
the space wells.
It just feels like
they're going to be a much bigger
part of the plot
in the second half of the series.
it if you spot any of their Easter eggs
or references in the trailer footage
that it didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
Michael episode for video we'll post
next week after they release it.
Congratulations to Gary from Brooklyn.
You're the giveaway
winner from my last big Star Wars episode.
Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
click here for my full Ahsoka
Episode three video
in the Easter Eggs and click here
for all my Ahsoka episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!